good morning Internet strangers and my
parents who watch these videos to make
sure that I am Alive
it is Wednesday ordinance grocer once or
Wednesday or I'm sure it probably does
not the car yet that's great it's a long
day today there's a ton of [ __ ] going on
and so I didn't have a chance to sit
down and actually make you a video today
I apologize so I thought I just take you
along this day with me Mabry and I are
going to a meeting right now she's not
here she's driving herself because we're
adults and we have a healthy sense of
separation and watch that's what she
says hi
she was a baby and her mom was watching
her with her hands I'm wearing
sweatpants to meetings I've officially
crossed the line but I'm going in with
confidence on this one that this is the
right choice and once this choice passes
all these meetings and I can do it over
and over and do it once set of
precedents and then you can do it as
much and then I'll be that girl that the
swap had some meetings and talked to
herself on the street
who just got out of a very exciting
meeting sweatpants still in tech really
cool stuff
and now mamrie and I are off to a second
meeting that guy can always rely on them
to be boring second meeting is done this
is not as eventful for you guys as I
thought okay I'm now headed to my agents
office to sit in a room and talk on the
phone and she you press outlets about
the secret project that's getting
announced tomorrow and that you guys
should be really excited for great video
high-quality content there was that
meeting now I'm in traffic hi friends I
am headed to go to @midnight
I'm shooting an episode of @midnight
that I think is enough on Thursday way
to kind of heart and Harley Morenstein
plays he has the same epic Meal Time
let's go oh oh hi it's a magic secret
secret secret secret secret secret Zig
how'd she get a flower in her room
okay goodbye I'm now in another hotel
room because I'm down at VidCon which
for a lot of you that don't know VidCon
is the YouTube convention in Anaheim
California it is a really wonderful
convention and I just got down here it
is 1:00 a.m. so it's why I'm sorry that
this video has been uploaded earlier
Thursday night at midnight on @midnight
you can see Hannah Hart Harley
Morenstein and I on @midnight really
really fun otherwise lots of really
special projects are being announced
here at my gun so just tuned in to the
interwebs says you're out of touch aunt
I don't know hello I have I am now in my
hotel room hello hi I was just wondering
if there were any one if in room/dining
was still serving and if not if you knew
of any places that's deliver 24 hours
okay
um do you know what what place I'm sorry
hello